WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Say hello
to Android Things 1.0,
Google's managed
operating system
for building and
maintaining Internet
of Things devices at scale.
I'm Wayne Piekarski,
and today I'm
going to explain what's new in
version 1.0, how it provides
long-term support for
production devices,
and a new lineup of
system-on-module hardware.
So what is Android Things?
Android Things is Google's
managed operating system
that enables you to build
and maintain Internet
of Things devices at scale.
We provide a robust platform
that does the heavy lifting,
with certified hardware,
rich developer APIs,
and secure, managed
software updates using
Google's backend
infrastructure, so you can
focus on building your product.
Version 1.0 is the first
release of Android Things
that is ready for your
production devices.
We just recently completed
our developer preview,
and the preview SDK was
downloaded over 100,000 times.
Developer feedback
and engagement
has been critical in
our journey towards 1.0,
and we're grateful to
the 10,000 developers who
have provided us feedback
through filing bugs,
attending events, and
posting in our communities.
A core part of our IoT platform
is the supported hardware,
based on a System-On-Module,
or SOM, design.
So what is this?
A SOM is a fully
integrated component
with CPU, memory, wi-fi
Bluetooth, and flash storage,
that you can just drop
into your final design,
just like you would use a
library when writing software.
The SOM is certified by Google,
and we provide a board support
package that includes the
kernel, drivers, and libraries
to support Android.
With Android Things 1.0, we've
announced support for SOMs
based on designs from NXP,
Qualcomm, and MediaTek,
and these modules are
certified for production use,
and available in quantities to
make real consumer products.
If you want to try Android
Things right now without buying
a SOM, you can even use any
one of developing platforms,
even the Raspberry
Pi 3, and this
highlights an important
feature of Android Things.
It's quick and easy
for prototyping,
and when you're
ready for production,
there's a clear
path to buying SOMs
in small or large quantities,
depending on your needs,
and then your software
is ready to go.
You can then design your own
Printed Circuit Board, or PCB,
to connect your
hardware to the SOM.
When building IoT devices,
maintaining security
is very important.
Providing timely software
updates Over The Air, or OTA,
is a fundamental part of
that, and stability fixes
and security patches
are supported
on production
hardware platforms,
and automatic updates are
enabled for all devices
by default. For each
Android Things version,
Google will offer free stability
fixes and security patches
for three years, with additional
options for extended support.
Even after the official
support window ends,
you'll still be able
to continue to push
app updates to your devices.
Use the Android Things
console to upload Android
APKs with your updates so the
OTA mechanism can push them out
to your devices.
You can initially experiment
with 100 active devices
for noncommercial use.
When you're ready
for mass production,
we'll provide you with a
distribution agreement,
and now you're ready
to sell your devices
in large quantities
to the public.
With Android Things,
you can build
apps using the rich framework
provided by the Android SDK
and Google Play services,
including the same UI tool
kit, multimedia support,
and connectivity APIs used
by mobile developers today.
You can also easily
integrate your apps
with popular Google services,
like Firebase, TensorFlow,
and Cloud IT Core.
This is done using the many
existing Android client
libraries.
And since it's
Android, you can use
Android Studio and all of its
languages and tools, right out
of the box.
This means you can easily
program and debug in Kotlin,
Java, C++, or C,
depending on your needs.
Who else is using
Android Things?
You may have seen the new
voice-activated speakers
from Polk, LG, and iHome,
as well as smart displays
from Lenovo, LG, and JBL.
These devices showcase
the powerful capabilities
of the Google Assistant, and are
coming soon to stores near you.
There are also lots of startups
and design agencies using
Android Things to
prototype innovative ideas
for all kinds of devices
you're going to see very soon.
We want to make it easy for
anyone to start building IoT
devices, without having
to own your own factory,
and without requiring
lots of funding.
This is all part of our
efforts to democratize hardware
development, making it
accessible to more software
developers out there.
If you want to get started
with Android Things,
we have a great
community website,
AndroidThings.withgoogle.com,
where
you can see the developer kits
and the interesting projects
created by others.
So what's next?
Get some hardware, check
out the documentation,
download some sample source
code, and try it out.
And join our community
to ask questions
and share your
ideas with others.
Android Things 1.0 is
now open for business
and ready for production.
I'm really looking
forward to seeing
all the exciting
products that you build.
I'm Wane Piekarski, and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]